the work which which was done in 1964
led to the so-called electroweak theory
the unification of weak and
electromagnetic interactions in
elementary particles which was done in
1967 by Weinberg and Salam by taking a
ferry which had the right kind of
unification but but couldn't couldn't
produce good calculations due to gosh oh
and and putting it combining it with the
kind of models of symmetry breaking
which we had discussed in 64 that was
the beginning of the standard mold
because once that theory was shown to be
mathematically sound that you could
really calculate with it people started
to study other other other kinds of
so-called gauge theory in relation to
the other forces in particle physics and
those those investigations led on to a
theory of the strong forces well called
quantum chromodynamics so they work in
64 was the beginning of the return of
this kind of so-called quantum field
theory in particle physics it had
previously became been successful in the
50s quantum quantum electrodynamics and
then became neglected in particle
physics because it didn't seem to work
and what we did was a step on the way to
making it work